bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat pour suivre dans un
instant les débats des sénateurs qui ont
débuté hier sur la loi Sapin 2 et hier
la Haute Assemblée s'est intéressée à
l'un des points Phard du texte les
lanceurs d'alertees leur définition mais
aussi leur protection alors hier les
sénateurs ont suivi la volonté de la
commission des lois la majorité
sénatoriale qui a voulu encadrer la
protection des lanceurs d'alertes et qui
les a définis comme toute personne
physique qui signale dans l'intérêt
général de manière désintéressée et de
bonne foi un crime un délit ou la
violation d'une loi ou d'un règlement
dont il a eu personnellement
connaissance et cela au grandâ de la
gauche qui a trouvé cette définition
trop restrictive notez également que le
texte mentionne très rapidement
également les sanctions en cour ru en
cas de faux lancement d'alerte hier
Notter que les débats et bien ont
également porté sur le lux le cette
affaire d'exil fiscal de multinationales
organisé avec l'aval de du fisque
luxembourgeois c'est invité dans
l'hémicycle je vous rappelle que Antoine
Deltour le lanceur d'alerte qui a
dénoncé cette situation a été condamné
par la justice luxembourgeoise à 12 mois
de prison avec surc et bien hier de
nombreux sénateurs se sont demandés si
le texte tel qu'adopté tel que modifié
par le Sénat aurait suffisamment protégé
le lanceur d'alerte tout de suite donc
retour au débat dans
l'hémicycle nous abordons maintenant les
dispositions relatives au lanceur
d'alerte et si vous le permettez je
voudrais vous dire un mot de l'esprit
qui a animé les les travaux de la
commission monsieur le ministre nous ne
sommes pas éloignés sur le plan
intellectuel vous recherchez un
équilibre nous aussi nous ne trouvons
pas le même point d'équilibre mais c'est
déjà un bon point de
départ les lanceurs d'alertes jouent un
rôle très utile dans notre société il ne
se résume pas à ceux d'entre eux qui ont
alerté la presse pour des fraudes
massives des délits très graves la
pratique de l'alerte peut-être une
pratique qui reste confidentielle
l'important c'est que l'alerte aboutisse
notre souci de protection des lanceurs
d'alertes est légitime mais il ne va pas
sans souci aussi de protection de ceux
qui peuvent faire l'objet de
dénonciation abusives nos concitoyens
non pas les lseurs d'alerte de ceux qui
peuvent faire l'objet de calomnie de
diffamation souvenons-vous
souvenons-nous mes chers collègues des
des propos du président François
mitteran aux obsèques de Pierre
bergovois lorsqu'il fustigeait ce qui
dans les médias avait euh jeté en pâure
l'honneur d'un homme au chien
cette forte intervention du président
mitteran était parfaitement justifié par
l'emballement qui s'empare parfois des
médias dans des affaires de corruption
pour lesquels il n a en réalité pas
matière à poursuite ni même à
condamnation faisons très attention que
nous sommes nous les gardiens d'intérêts
qui sont des intérêts multiples
l'intérêt du lanceur d'alerte qu'il
convient de protéger bien sûr évidemment
l'intérêt des victimes éventuelles de
dénonciation abusive aussi et c'est la
raison pour laquelle notre recherche
d'équilibre nous a conduit à définir un
cadre plus précis pour permettre
d'assurer la
conformité à la loi et au souci de
défendre des intérêts contradictoires de
l'alerte et du lanceur d'alerte ça veut
dire d'abord qu'une définition de
l'alerte doit être donnée qui soit
précise des crimes des des délits une
violation grave et manifeste de la loi
et non pas un simple manquement ça veut
dire aussi qu'un lanceur d'alerte de
bonne foi doit démontrer sa bonne foi en
passant d'abord par l'employeur la
hiérarchie
administrative le référent désigné
éventuellement par l'employeur et à des
il doit passer par l'autorité
administrative ou l'autorité judiciaire
ou l'ordre professionnel il faut laisser
le temps à ces institutions de réagir 3
mois sauf dans le cas où il y a un
risque de dommage grave et irréversible
enfin nous n'avons pas permis parce que
ce ne sont pas des institutions qui ont
compétences pour le faire à des
syndicats à des associations agréées au
Défenseur des droits de recevoir
l'alerte lancée par le donneur d'alerte
ils n'ont d'ailleurs pas de moyen de
faire prospérer cette alerte autrement
qu'en prenant à témoin l'opinion
publique nous voulons donner sa chance à
l'alerte qui va entraîner une réaction
et qui n'a pas besoin forcément de
passer par la prise à témoin de
l'opinion publique voilà l'économie
générale de notre travail nous avons
également mais nous y reviendrons
considéré qu'il n'appartenait pas au
Défenseur des droits qui ne le réclame
pas d'ailleurs d'apporter un
dédommagement préalable au lanceur
d'alerte alors qu'une procédure
judiciaire permettra de déterminer ou
non si l'alerte avait été donné de bonne
foi et si un dommage devait un préjudice
devait être reconnu en faveur du lanceur
d'alerte ne créons pas une inégalité
fondamental entre justiciables avec des
justiciables qui seraient pris en charge
et recevrai un accomte sur leur dommage
par le Défenseur des droits et d'autres
justiciabl qui n'aurait comme seul
recours que l'aide
juridictionnelle merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre
monsieur le Président en remerciant le
président bas d'avoir éclairé
l'assemblée j'aimerais aussi me placer à
ce niveau-là de généralité mais au fond
du débat après nous rentrerons dans les
dans les détails si nous voulons et je
crois que nous partageons cette idée
mettre en place une protection efficace
des lanceurs d'alertes nous pouvons le
faire qu'à trois conditions qui vont
être discuté la première la plus
importante j'y reviendrai c'est la
définition qu'est-ce qu'un lanceur
d'alerte je le disais dans le débat il
suffit pas de s'appeler lanceur d'alerte
pour l'airtre obligatoirement la
définition deuxième point il faut un
canal de révélation des faits je pense
que sur ce point il y a des différences
d'appréciation mais nous devrions
pouvoir converger puis après il y a les
modalité de la protection elle-même
c'est là-dessus que nous avons aussi une
divergence pour savoir quel est
l'organisme qui peut accompagné protéger
quel est le rôle de la justice là encore
il y a un rôle de la justice et est-ce
qu'il n'est pas nécessaire de mettre en
place un accompagnement j'appelle ça
accompagnement pas des dommagement parce
qu'on est pas dans l'indemnité
l'indemnité le calcul du montant du
préjudice c'est le juge il est le seul à
pouvoir calculer le montant du préjudice
avec tous les aspects de ce préjudice
matériel immatériel et cetera mais il y
a un accompagnement l'accompagnement le
plus visible c'est il y a une procédure
judiciaire ça coûte cher est-ce que on
l'accompagne ou pas dans cette projé
nous nous proposons de l'accompagner je
crois d'ailleurs sur ce point il y a pas
forcément une grande différence entre
nous j'ai plus en tête mais il y a aussi
la question de l'accompagnement
financier je connais des lanceurs
d'alerte qui sont retrouvés du jour au
lendemain sans rien à qui la justice a
donné ensuite évidemment raison mais il
y a une période plutôt difficile et
compliquée à vivre même parfois terrible
à vivre donc ça c'est les modalités de
la protection je le répète non pas le
préjudice mais la modalité de la
protection nous en parlerons aussi je ne
pense pas que nous soyons si éloignés je
reviens à la question de la définition
parce que ça c'est le sujet
fondamental et quand je regarde nous en
parlerons par que c'est le premier
article qui viendra après quand je
regarde la rédaction adoptée par la
commission ne sont lanceurs d'alerte que
ceux qui révèlent des faits délictueux
ou criminels uniquement des faits
délectueux ou criminels c'est-à-dire que
le cas de Monsieur Deltour n'est pas
couvert par la définition actuelle il ne
peut pas l'être puisqu'il a révélé des
faits qui n'étaient pas
délictueux au Luxembourg mais
profondément
anormaux dommageable à l'intérêt général
à Morau oui aussi mais anormaux en tous
les cas est tellement dommageable que à
la suite de cette révélation la la la
législation a été modifiée au Luxembourg
et comme je le disais aussi dans mon
intervention l'ensemble des pays
européens ont mis en place par le biais
d'une directive les mêmes modalité de
lutte contre ce type d'opacité fiscale
c'est sur ce point que vraiment je vous
demande d'y réfléchir c'est pas del tour
pour Deltour mais c'est parce qu'il
illustre exactement très clairement un
des points importants du rôle d'un
lanceur d'alerte c'est pas seulement
cette jeune femme qui a révélé des faits
illégaux d'UBS en France ce sont des
faits illégaux d'ailleurs UBS est
aujourd'hui poursuivi y compris pour
blanchiment de fraude fiscale mais dans
le cas de luxleix je leurai dit ici ce
ne sont pas des faits à l'époque
illégaux et pourtant il a bien fait et
donc il il mérite d'être protégé donc
c'est sur ce point vraiment monsieur le
Président et j'arrêterai là parce que le
débat continuera sur l'article qui qui
suit c'est là le cœur du sujet et je
souhaite que ça ne soit pas le cœur du
désaccord entre
nous merci Monsieur le Ministre alors
j'avais trois paroles on va essayer de
les prendre avant 20h avant de souper
vous tenez vos vos temps sinon on peut
pas le faire hein monsieur col en bas
aussi ça en fait quatre bon ben écoutez
on va interrompre la séance parce
que ah Monsieur rapporteur vous
souhaiitiez sur la même d'accord
allez-y oui pour éclairer ce débat comme
nous l'avons fait tout à l'heure afin
d'ailleurs peut-être tout à l'heure
simplifier les discussions sur sur les
les amendements les les les lanceurs
d'alertees on a tous la vision de ceux
que nous avons cité ou évoqué depuis le
début et nous sommes tous d'accord mais
le texte que nous allons faire ne va pas
uniquement être utilisé que par ces
lanceurs d'alerte là il y aura les
lanceurs d'alertes le flot éventuel de
lanceurs d'alerte qui arriveront euh
relatif à de petites entreprises ou à
des PME et si la situation des lanceurs
d'alerte est difficile est-ce que la
situation des victimes n'est pas
difficile lorsqu'ils ont été victimes
d'une fausse alerte ou d'une rumeur je
vais prendre un exemple je vous prendre
un exemple imaginons une société de de
de restauration spécialisée dans la
viande qui euh se voit dénoncer parce
qu'elle vendrait du cheval ou vendrait
de la viande qui ne serait pas
parfaitement
homologué lancement de
l'alerte chute de la clientèle chute du
euh des du Chi d'affaires et puis X
années après après que il y a eu une
perte de la valeur de entreprise que
peut-être si elle avait déposé le bilan
ça aurait été des licenciements en masse
5 6 ans après ordonnance de nonlieu
passé il y avait strictement rien à voir
on doit aussi se préoccuper de ces
situations là dans une PME PME en pleine
en pleine campagne vous avez un lanceur
d'alerte qui de bonne foi d'ailleurs dit
attendez moi les effluant qui sortent de
l'entreprise pas bon pas bon du tout
pour le le le le ruisseau dans lequel s
s'est déversé le lanceur d'alerte
lanceon affaire émotion générale émotion
générale qui aboutit à une perte totale
de la clientèle de l'entreprise dépôt de
bilan 50 emplois en moins et 2 3 ans
après on s'apertooit que certes les
fluents étaient blanchâtres je parle en
connaissance de cause les fluents
étaient blanchâre mais aucune polltion
rien quel est le dégât qu'on a commis
quel est le dégât qu'on a commis c'est à
cela que la commission des finances veut
vous faire réfléchir il pardon
excusez-moi mais veut bien faire
réfléchir aussi mais c'est la raison
pour laquelle c'est la raison pour
laquelle euh il faut sur ce point êre
particulièrement mesuré maintenant j'en
termine en prenant l'exemple de
d'Antoine deltou je vous rassure
monsieur le ministre la définition que
nous donnons les lois les règlement ou
une violation
manifeste des lois et des règlements
violation manifeste des lois des
règlements ça peut ne pas être un délit
c'est pas forcément un délit et Antoine
Deltour avec notre définition en
franceation França en France il est
protégé mais je comprends bien que la
France a vocation à éclairé le monde
mais il se trouve que le monde
quelquefois n'accepte pas l'éclairage de
la France ce qui fait que dans une
législation extérieure et en particulier
au Luxembourg où notre législation ne ne
passera pas la frontière Antoine delour
quelle que soit la loi en France et bien
il sera condamné au Luxembourg donc
c'est à cela aussi c'est ça les éléments
du BAB il sera pas condamné en France
mais il pourra être condamné en
Luxembourg mais
mais oui mais même s'il l'avait fait
s'il l'avait fait en France par exemple
s'il avait des dénoncé des montages
fiscaux allant au-delà de l'abus de
droit fiscal de l'ingénierie bon voilà
je me suis expliqué le débat est
beaucoup plus large attention on pense à
des des lanceurs d'alerte qu'on a bien
en tête bien la volonté de de de
protéger attention aux autres que la loi
va suggérer merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur Éric Boquet pour
parole ah oui on a
inversé avec Monsieur abat vous me
compliquez la tâche
oui alors effectivement monsieur le
ministre le verdict est tombé mercredi
dernier qui a condamné Antoine Deltour
et et Raphaël alleé le premier avait
reçu le prix du citoyen européen en juin
2015 le second n'a pas eu cette chance
une clause de confidentialité l'a
empêché de faire une sortie publique
entre guillemets et d'obtenir une telle
reconnaissance les lanceurs d'alertes
euh étaient reconnus mais cependant la
loi luxembourgeoise et les directives
européennes ne permettaiit pas de les
protéger ce procès
luxliix particulièrement révélateur s
ouvert peu de temps avant le vote à
l'Assemblée nationale du projet de loi
qui nous occupe aujourd'hui la
définition effectivement du lanceur
d'alerte adopté en première lecture sur
laquelle est malheureusement revenue la
commission des Lois du Sénat nous allait
plutôt bien assez bien le texte
prévoyait de protéger toute personne
mais quand même
euh on avait oublié en tout cas pas
clairement indiqué celle
qui dénoncit des actes contraires à à
l'intérêt général au sens de
l'optimisation fiscale et il est
effectivement nécessaire de proposer une
définition véritablement protectrice et
le nœud du problème notre ambition doit
être un dispositif qui fasse école qui
soit qui soit efficace qui soit
respectueux de la vie privée qui qui
disqualifie les aventuriers qui
répondent à ses préoccupations monsieur
le rapporteur monsieur le Président que
vous aviez évoqué alors comparaison
n'est pas raison quoi que quelquefois
oui alors j'oserai un parallèle avec un
dispositif que tout le monde connaît
bien c'est celui qui encadre
l'assistance ou la non assistance à
personnes en danger en effet le lanceur
d'alerte ne fait rien d'autre que
d'assister la société en danger première
remarque ça devrait impliquer que c'est
pas le lanceur d'alerte qui devrait être
embêté c'est celui qui fait de la non
assistance à société en danger qui
devrait avoir des soucis qui devrait
être l'objet de poursuite en tout état
de cause l'assistance ou la non
assistance à personnes endagé ne font
plus de de de débat juridique il y a pas
de problème philosophique on se pose
plus de questions et je pense qu'on
pourrait faire pareil avec un lanceur
d'alerte deux exemples l'assistance à
personne en danger n'autorise pas à
faire un acte chirurgique
sur un un accidenté de la route sans
même avoir appelé le SAMU et sans avoir
attendu un minimum l'arrivée des
professionnels on est fautif et on paye
deuxième exemple et j'arrêterai là
monsieur le Président l'assistance à
personne en danger nautorise pas un
voisin à forcer la porte de sa voisine
en en en prétendant qu'il a entendu
appeler au secours pour le simple
plaisir de lui faire du mal il serait
aussi et ça pe être il réversible le mal
qui lui ferait ce serait aussi
condamnable alors je pense que si on
avait cette vision cette philosophie
cette approche des choses on se
simplifierait la vie et le lanceur
d'alerte serait effectivement protégé
par une définition très large merci pour
votre attention et mes excuses pour le
dépassement merci Monsieur abat je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
21h30 pour la suite de l'examen de ce
texte la séance est
suspendue la séance est reprise l'ordre
du jour appelle la discussion du projet
de loi adopté par l'Assemblée nationale
après engagement de la procédure
accélérée relatif à la transparence à la
lutte contre la corruption et à la
modernisation de la vie
économique et de la proposition de loi
organique adoptée par l'Assemblée
nationale après engagement de la
procédure accélérée relative à la
compétence du Défenseur des droits pour
pour l'orientation et la protection des
lanorts d'alerte dans la discussion des
articles du projet de loi nous sommes
parvenus à l'article 6 A et je vais
donner la parole à Madame mariechristine
Blandin merci monsieur le Président cet
article 6a avec sa définition donne tout
son sens au renforcement de ce projet de
loi par le thème de l'alerte à ce jour
nous avons déjà C textes sur l'alerte et
chacun s'accorde à constater qu'ils ont
tous des imperfection et que leur
ensemble futile vaste ne couvre pas tous
les champs pire la mosaïque de ces cinq
textes et l'imprécision de certains
termes peut dans un tribunal laisser des
arguments aux avocats qui voudrai
obtenir condamnation du lanceur d'alerte
c'est donc une ambition qui honore les
les auteurs et vous-même monsieur le
ministre que de vouloir un socle commun
et la description des procédures
adaptables selon les cas et je voudrais
que l'on me dise si je suis dans
l'erreur mais cette définition est
prévue pour être
exhaustive donc elle doit pouvoir
couvrir les fuites
financières comme les fuites de benzen
or beaucoup de descriptions du lanceur
d'alerte présenté par nos collègues
oublient les fuites de bzen dans
l'histoire on dirait qu'ils sont tous
sortis de Bery et ça ça pose un problème
ou alors on dit il y a d'autres partie
du code qui s'occupe d'autres types de
lanceur d'alerte le Conseil d'État bien
éclairé le sujet d'ailleurs je suis
heureuse qu'il est reconnu la qualité
des propositions de ma loi de
2013 petit règlement de compte je me
souviens qu'à l'époque monsieur le
ministre vous l'aviez quelque peu érodé
en pesant de tout votre poids pour que
soit supprimé à l'Assemblée nationale le
droit à la formation spécifique des
membres du CHSCT en cas d'alerte dommage
c'était une proposition de la commission
des affaires sociales du Sénat j'ai noté
aussi que vous aviez à propos d'un
amendement à l'assemblée que proposait
la part qui proposait la participation
de la Commission nationale de
déontologie des alertes en matière de
santé d'environnement un peu perscifflé
sur sa
nonexistence vous avez raison elle
n'existe pas mais quand on perscifle
c'est qu'on en veut un ennemi or nous
sommes partenaires nous ramons dans le
même sens ou bien qu'on veut souligner
la défaillance de l'autre mais qui est
défaillant sur les 25 membres 23 ont été
nommé sauf les deux qui viennent du
gouvernement pourquoi ne veut-on pas
aller cette commission gêne-t-elle
quelques grandes firmes
pharmaceutiqu enfin la loi est votée les
décrets sont sortis il ne manque plus
que deux
nominations merci Madame Marie-Christine
Blandin la parole est à monsieur Éric
bequet oui merci monsieur le Président
quelques mots en complément de ce que
notre collègue Patrick abat a dit
excellemment tout à l'heure je pas
répéter la même chose trois idées
simplement la première idée c'est la
situation concrète des lanceurs
d'alertes parce que on évoque que cette
notion parfois comme quelque chose d'un
peu virtuel potentiel mais c'est très
concret et dans la pratique les lanceurs
d'alertes s'oppose s'expose plutôt à des
représailles de de tous ordres qui
prennent des formes multiples qui
peuvent aller du licenciement abusif à
la diffamation à la mise au placard
sanction disciplinaire et cetera et
malheureusement l'actualité est riche en
exemple de ce type qui illustre ce
constat je vais pas les réénumérer ici
donc le plus souvent les salariés sont
démunis face à l'alerte euh faute d'une
législation donc c'est ce qui est en
train de se mettre en place et c'est une
bonne chose de procédure et
d'interlocuteurs connus et transparency
internationale a fait un sondage en
novembre dernier indiquant que les gens
garderaient le silence face à des actes
de corruption euh il le ferait non pas
par peur des représailles dans le 39 %
des cas ou parce qu'il pense qu'aucune
suite ne sera donnée à cette alerte pour
euh 40 % des cas de plus une large
majorité des salariés français ne savent
pas à qui s'adresser pour mettre mettre
fin à de telles pratiques donc
effectivement nous apportons ici une
réponse concrète avec cette agence
deuxième point effectivement je crois
que nos rapporteurs ont raison de
d'avoir en tête le risque de fausse
alertes de diffamation de rumeurs
infondé oui le risque existe mais je
pense que on peut faire confiance à
l'agence pour agir avec discernement
avec les moyens dont elle disposera pour
séparer vous me permettrez cette image
le bon grain de livret en matière
d'alerte dans des situations quelles
qu'elles soient et puis troisème point
les j'évoquerai le cas de
Deltour qui a été condamné parce que il
a enfraint le droit luxembourgeois
effectivement le secret bancaire et une
disposition légale au Luxembourg mais le
la législation des États évolue avec
l'histoire et demain peut-être que il
sera reconnu qu'il a rendu service à
l'intérêt général et c'est
fondamentalement ce que je pense après
tout l'apartide depuis 1948 en Afrique
du Sud était légal contester enfreindre
dénoncer laartail c'était enfreindre la
loi l'esclavage en son temps fut légal
également donc laissons le temps aussi à
la loi d'évoluer les gens s'en chargent
et donc tout ce que l'on dit aujourd'hui
peut-être que demain ça sera reconnu
voilà merci merci monsieur Éric bequet
Monsieur Pierre Yve Colomba
oui tous ces débats m amener à à dire
deux mots je voudrais d'abord première
remarque que je voudrais faire c'est que
on n'est pas là pour légiférer sur ce
qui se passe au
Luxembourg deuxè 2uxème chose les
condamnations euh qui ont qui ont eu
lieu au Luxembourg sont
scandaleuses mais je dois dire que on
permett ce genre de pratique légale au
Luxembourg c'est encore plus
scandaleux pour reprendre le
l'expression de notre ancien collègue
Jean artui euh notre ce ce le président
de de la
commission Junker de la commission le
matin il nous fait les poches et le
lendemain on Fa le matin il nous fait la
la leçon sur notre déséquilibre
budgétaire et le et l'après-midi il nous
fait les poches avec ces ces facilités
ces facilités fiscales alors je voudrais
je voudrais pas être méchant monsieur le
ministre c'est pas dans ma nature
mais franchement s'il y a quelque chose
à faire c'est c'est pas à pondre un
texte sur enfin d'urgence c'est pas un
texte sur les lanceurs d'alertes c'est
faire cesser ce scandale permanent une
Europe qui vit sur sur quel enfin sur ça
bon donc ça je vais pas faire ensuite
s'il s'agit maintenant strictement des
lanceurs
d'alerte ça me paraît quand même un peu
difficile d'autoriser des pratiques
illégales qu'est-ce que c'est que
qu'est-ce que c'est que un lanceur
d'alerte en fait c'est une personne qui
de part sa profession a des informations
donc à des renseignements que les autres
n'ont pas mais qui est situation de
dépendance d'une façon ou d'une autre
donc il s'agit dans ce cadre- là de lui
assurer effectivement l'immunité et le
hasard faisant bien les choses on ma
fait passer
une un arrêt de de la cour de de la cour
de de la Cour de cassation sur une
affaire sur une affaire qui vient que
qui est intervenu il y a quelques temps
mais qui vient juste de d'être d'être
publié et qui nous dit qu'est-ce quel
est le périmètre de l'alerte en fait il
en résulte de cet arrêt que il s'agit de
conduite ou acte illicite constaté sur
le lieu du travail susceptible de
caractériser une infraction pénale je
crois que c'est difficile de sortir de
ça le pour le reste mon cher collègue
effectivement ils sont en avance mais
les révolutionnaires sont toujours en
avance monsieur
Colomba un amendement
309 monsieur
oui monsieur le Président d'abord je
crois que les suspensions ont beaucoup
d'intérêt puisque c'est m' permis de
réfléchir un peu à ces débats et de
repenser aux paroles qui ont été
prononcées à la fois par le rapporteur
et puis après par notre président de la
commission des lois et finalement quand
j'écoute leur parole je me dis mais ils
ont raison on partage tout nous avons la
même ambition et puis ensuite après je
reviens ici et je relis je dois dire que
l'écrit est différent de l'oral et que
autant l'oral je me dit finalement on
peut partager autant l'écrit je me dis
ça va pas qu'est-ce qui ne va pas on
nous explique qu'au fond la définition
du lanceur d'alerte est très simple
dénoncer un crime ou un délit et un peu
plus mais juste un peu plus mais s'il ne
s'agit que de ça dénoncer un crime on n
pas besoin d'instituer un droit d'alerte
et de protéger des lanceurs d'alertes on
a l'article 434 ti 1 du Code pénal qui
nous dit que toute personne qui ne
dénonce pas un crime et bien estible
d'une peine de prison donc le code pénal
suffirait si on veut faire un lanceur
d'alerte c'est pour aller plus loin que
ce que prévoit le code pénal c'est aller
plus loin que la dénonciation des crimes
et des délits et on l'a expliqué à
plusieurs reprises et moi je voudrais
quand même demander ici à tous nos
collègues du Sénat de ne pas avoir la
main qui tremble est-ce que nous voulons
avoir une définition duanceur d'alerque
qui soit encore en retrait de tout ce
que nous connaissons je
lisais quelques décision et quelques
recommandations par exemple la
recommandation du Conseil de l'Europe du
30 avril 2014 le conseil de l'EUR
recommande aux États-membres de disposer
d'un cadre normatif institutionnel et
judiciaire pour protéger les personnes
qui font des signalements révèle des
informations concernant des menaces ou
un préjudice pour l'intérêt général nous
sommes bien en de ça et je disait une
note des nations- Unies du 18 septembre
2015 qui précisait que le lanceur
l'arrête est une personne qui dévoile
des informations qu'elle a des motifs
raisonnables de croire véridiques au
moment où elle procède à leur
divulgation et qui porte sur des faits
dont elle juge qu'il constiue une menace
ou un prégise pour un intérêt général
enfin mes collègues est-ce que vous
voulez que constamment nous soyons en
retrait de tout ce qui se passe dans le
monde et que nous donnons ainsi un très
mauvais exemple est-ce que vous voulez
qu'une nouvelle fois le scénna
apparaisse comme étant le grand timon de
la République faisant deux pas en avant
et trois pas en arrière ou deux pas en
avant et deux pas en arrière c'est une
question je crois d'image aussi du Sénat
ne donnons pas cette impression d'un
Sénat qui a peur de toute innovation
merci merci Monsieur
Anziani monsieur le rapporteur merci
monsieur le Président
non le Sénat n'a pas
peur le Sénat se veut mesurer équilibrer
il réfléchit à l'équilibre des libertés
il n'a pas peur il est là rempart
précisément à certaines à certaines
libertés et comme je l'expliquéis tout à
l'heure euh s'il faut trouver une
définition des lanceurs d'alerte s'il
faut effectivement protéger certains
lanceurs d'alertees il faut pas négliger
pour autant que le système s'il est mal
établi s'il est mal écrit provoquera
aussi des victimes et des victimes
collatérales comme j'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure alors on a tous le devoir de
trouver une définition on va se heurter
sur la définition on va peut-être pas y
arriver euh aujourd'hui à trouver une
une définition mais alors je reviens sur
la votre sur celle sur celle de votre
amendement bon alors elle est contraire
à la position de la Commission cela dit
j'aurais pu tout dire et puis j'ai rien
dit là vous vous vous définissez comme
lanceur d'alerte toute personne
dénonçant un manquement au droit en
vigueur mais qu'est-ce que c'est le
droit en vigueur est-ce que est-ce que
ça prend les conventions internationales
raétifiées est-ce que ça prend la
Convention internationale sur les droits
de l'enfant est-ce que ça prend en
compte la coutume internationale nous
dans la définition c'est les lois et
règlements c'est bien a le droit en
vigueur mais au moins c'est clair et
précis après vous dans votre amendement
vous visez à élargir encore la
définition en permettant toute
dénonciation de je vous cite menace ou
préjudice grave pour l'intérêt général
menace pour l'intérêt général c'est tout
m ouvrir une faille comment on va
interpréter le mot menace qu'est-ce
qu'une menace alors même ça ça peut
avoir un effet contraire votre
définition parce que est-ce que ça
protège vraiment le lanceur d'alerte une
définition qui n'est pas très précise
pas certain parce que qu'est-ce que
feront les juge de cette menace
qu'est-ce qu'ils considéreront comme une
menace alors voilà donc ce qui me fait
dire que nous nous ne partageons pas
certes la même définition nous pensons
pour vous quielle est plus large pour
moi quielle est plus protectrice à la
fois des victimes mais aussi des
lanceurs d'alertees et puis surtout je
vous rappelle que la définition du
lanceur d'alerte de de cette définition
n'est une irresponsabilité pénale or on
peut pas faire reposer euh les effets
juridiques d'une définition aussi
imprécise sur une définition aussi
imprécise je crains même que au au bout
la jurisprudence constitutionnelle est
particulièrement exigeante en matière
pénale et je ne suis pas certain sur ce
point qu'elle ne trouve pas précisément
votre texte comme insuffisamment précis
donc j'en reste là vous verrez que dans
notre texte nous parlons de violation
manifeste loi et règlement l'intérêt
général la bonne foi tout y est pour
préserver les lanceur d'alerte qui ont
été encore une fois évoqués tout à
l'heure et pour lesquels on peut t avoir
de la sympathie même les exemples que je
vous ai donné que je peux multiplier à
la envie pose quand même aussi problème
parce que si nous faisons une loi que
dans 5 ans ou même avant nous sommes
obligés de revenir parce que nous aurons
eu trois ou quatre affaires de lanceur
d'alertes qui n'étaient pas des vrais
lanceurs d'alertes et qu'on aura eu au
tapis 200 ou 300 emplois et des
entreprises importantes il faudra
recommencer donc voilà la raison pour
laquelle je j'aiimis un avis défavorable
mais vous nêtes pas surpris merci
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre j'ai une difficulté monsieur le
Président c'est que je présente un
amendement d'autres aussi qui réécrit
l'alinéa premier or cet amendement
réécrit l'ensemble de l'article et donc
discuter avant tout à fait légitimement
sur votre procédure il m'est pas
possible de ce que je voudrais faire
sans expliquer le mien qui me paraît
plus convenir et compris en allant dans
le sens de Monsieur Anani donc je ne
sais pas monsieur le Président comment
vous souhaitez
faire parce que je je fais une
proposition le gouvernement fait une
propition d'autres font des des
propositions gouvernement tout ou alors
ou alors il il modifie l'alinéa premier
au quel cas il est en discussion commune
avec les autres d'accord
on
rectifie il est il est retiré
ou il est
rectifi
attendez donc ce que vous souhaitez
c'est
qu'on alinéa 1 rédig alé donc vous appz
amendement rédiger C al alineéa 1 alé
1 sur les
suiv7 donc on va appeler l'amendement
417 madame Goulet mais mais je suis là
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet article
monsieur le ministre et Monsieur le le
rapporteur monsieur le Président de la
Commission des des lois est un article
extrêmement attendu par par que cette
définition nous nous l'attendons dans
une dans une législation totalement
disparate totalement fragmenté
totalement éclaté et vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure il y a beaucoup
d'hésitations sur le lanceur d'alerte
comme il y a beaucoup d'hésitations sur
l'action de groupe parce que ce sont des
procédures qui qui heurtent notre
démarche juridique habituelleors la
proposition de de rédaction que je vous
fais est la suivante un lanceur d'alerte
est une personne physique ou morale qui
signale dans l'intérêt général de
manière désintéressée et de bonne foi un
crime un délit ou une violation grave et
manifeste des droits fondamentaux de la
loi et du règlement dont elle a eu
personnellement connaissance cet
amendement intègre d'autres éléments que
ceux qui ont été signalé précédemment et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
que c'est la meilleure rédaction par
rapport à l'ensemble des amendements qui
sont en discussion
commune merci le 6
46 monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président merci
infiniment en tous les cas d'avoir
accédé à à ma demande pour clarifier
notre notre débat nous sommes sur un des
points les plus importants en tous les
cas de cette partie du texte la
définition du lanceur d'alerte c'est ce
qui conditionne au fond l'ensemble de
l'application des autres disposition si
nous avons un dispositif trop restreint
il y a des gens que nous sommes prêts de
bonne fois les uns et les autres à
qualifier de lanceur d'alerte et qui ne
le serait pas devant le juge qui bien
bien entendu une définition restrictive
de ce que serait le lanceur d'alerte et
si nous faisons et c'est la
préoccupation de la commission une
définition trop large nous risquons de
d'embrasser des personnes dont aucun
d'entre nous n'est susceptible de
considérer qu'il s'agit de lanceur
d'alerte au sens où nous l'entendons les
uns et les autres donc il faut bien
calibrer ce dispositif euh deuxième
chose Monsieur Colomba avec sa fougue
habituelle nous dit nous ne légiférons
pas au Luxembourg heureusement de même
que
Luxembourg de même que le Luxembourg ne
légifère pas en France juste incidemment
au niveau européen puisque j'ai cru
comprendre qu'il y avait comme une
invitation à agir au niveau européen
c'est fait je vous le dis monsieur
Colomba c'est fait il y a une directive
qui a été appliquée avec transparence
avec mais non mais vous êtes toujours à
vouloir restreindre ça
y a sûrement des tas de choses à faire
en plus monsieur Colomba sûrement des
progr mais en l'occurrence en
l'occurrence une directive écoutez-moi
une directive a été adoptée elle est
appliquée dans l'ensemble des pays elle
est appliquée en France qui fait qu'il y
a transparence entre administration
fiscale sur la situation fiscale de
chacun des pays si la transparence règle
le problème du paiement de l'impôt et en
l'occurrence attendez monsieur Colomba
en l'occurrence et je reprends mon calme
en l'occurrence les situations Lux leak
serait connu si elle continuait si elle
avaient perduré de l'administration
française qui aurait fait quoi qui
aurait considéré qu'il n'y avait pas
d'imposition réelle au Luxembourg et qui
aurait imposé en France les bénéfices
faits en France voilà exactement ce à
quoi aujourd'hui nous aboutissons et si
vous voulez regarder quelques-uns bah
voyons et si vous regardiez quelques-uns
des des événements qui nous ont marqué
récemment la vie judiciaire et la vie
fiscale de quelquesunes des grandes
entreprises vous comprendriez
qu'aujourd'hui ça fonctionne donc
lookxtiix aujourd'hui ça n'existe plus
mais ça a existé et ce que nous
souhaitons les uns et les autres c'est
qu'une situation de cette nature ne
puisse pas exister non pas au Luxembourg
ça n'est pas notre faitte mais ne puisse
pas exister en France et c'est la seule
raison pour laquelle nous prenons les
uns et les autres cet exemple de
Monsieur Deltour c'est pas parce que
Monsieur Deltour ça serait inapplicable
en France puisque c'est au Luxembourg
mais en France s'il y avait une
situation de cette nature est-ce que
Monsieur Deltour serait ou non un
lanceur d' voilà la question que je pose
pardon monsieur le rapporteur sauf à ce
que vraiment vous arriviez à me
convaincre de vos arguments et pas
seulement moi-même manifestement au sein
de cette Assemblée mais lorsque vous
dites une violation grave et manifeste
de la loi ou du règlement une violation
grave et manifeste de la loi et du
Règlement certes ça n'est pas forcément
un délit certes ça n'est pas forcément
un crime mais ça veut dire qu'une loi a
été transgressée par l'entreprise
au Luxembourg Lux lex la loi n'a pas été
transgressée par les entreprises elle a
pas été transgressé par les puisque
c'était la loi luxembourgeoise et c'est
cette loi luxembourgeoise et ses
conséquences qui sont apparues tellement
contraire à l'intérêt général que
Monsieur Deltour a considéré de son
devoir de le faire connaître à
l'extérieur je considère donc que votre
définition ne couvre pas ce cas-là c'est
la raison pour laquelle et de ce point
de vue-là je rejoins en grande partie
les propositions de Madame Goulet et
peut-être de beaucoup d'autres je
propose une définition qui a quoi comme
objectif le premier objectif c'est de
parler de la norme internationale je
vous me DIRIS ça va de soi elle est
applicable directement mais je pense
qu'il vaut mieux la citer ainsi et
ensuite c'est de faire allusion en
particulier à cette question du
préjudice grave pour l'intérêt général
qui me paraîtêtre la seule définition
qui aujourd'hui se permett de couvrir
des situations telles de Monsieur cell
que de Monsieur Deltour voilà exactement
l'objectif du gouvernement nous avons
beaucoup débattu de cela à l'Assemblée
nationale j'ai beaucoup réfléchi y
compris personnellement pour essayer de
trouver une rédaction parce que je suis
moi aussi très attaché à l'idée qu'il
faut pas en quelque sorte dissoudre ce
ce beau statut que nous voulons créer de
lanceur d'alerte dans une sorte de
marécage des diverses règlements de
compte personnels ça n'est pas notre
objectif donc j'ai beaucoup réfléchi et
je pense que cette rédaction est
peut-être pas la seule il faut jamais
considérer qu'il n'y a qu'une seule
rédaction possible mais en tous les cas
est une rédaction qui répond aux
préoccupations des uns et des autres
protéger des gens que nous considérez
comme des vrais lanceurs d'alerte sans
pour autant ouvrir le statut à des gens
dont nous considérons qu'il ne méritent
pas ce beau statut de lanceur d'alerte
merci monsieur le ministre le
sous-amendement numéro
651 madame
Blandin
c'est un amendement qui prend acte que
la meilleure des rédaction mentionne
l'intérêt général pour couvrir les cas
qui viennent d'être évoqués qui seraient
des translations en France de ce qui
s'est passer pour les lanceurs d'alertes
au Luxembourg néanmoins le mot intérêt
général et d'ailleurs madame deomeddi
l'a dit dans son intervention c'est
quand même quelque chose qui est sujet à
débat l' général d'ailleurs je vais vous
donner un exemple simple tous nos partis
politiques ont des programmes tous
prétendent défendre l'intérêt général
pourtant ils sont drôlement différents
donc ce sous-amendement mentionne des
secteurs précis la santé l'environnement
les finances publiques mais mentionne en
plus l'intérêt général mais au moins on
sait que ces domaines là seront
concernés comme des thèmes sur lesquels
on a le droit de faire de la alerte
petite précision pour Monsieur Colomba
dans cette loi le lanceur d'alerte n'est
pas seulement un salarié d'une
entreprise ça peut aussi être un Riverin
un citoyen témoin de quelque chose merci
Madame Blandin le 310 monsieur
Anziani 310 revient également sur sur la
définition avec cette question pourquoi
réduiton le lanceur d'alerte à une
personne physique pourquoi je comprends
toujours pas à moins
qu'onestime et c'est contraire à la
définition retenue par l'article 6a que
le lanceur d'alerte ne peut être qu'une
personne physique salariée d'une
entreprise mais quand on lit la
définition on voit que ce n'est pas
exactement ça alors pourquoi exclure une
ONG une on qui va s'apercevoir à un
moment donné qu'il y a quelques petits
problèmes dans dans fabrication de
médicaments ou dans d'autres activités
elle ne pourra pas être considérée comme
lanceur d'alerte pourquoi exclure une
association et ça peut être aussi un CRE
de personnes physiques qui se regroupe
et nous en sommes aujourd'hui souvent
avec des actions collectives et bien
l'association ne pourra pas une
organisation syndicale qui finalement
peut reprendre à son compte des
observation de salariés au sein de
l'entreprise et puis qui porte cette
question elle ne pourra pas et même
d'ailleurs une entreprise une société
qui à un moment donné s'apercevrait que
il y a une autre société il y a d'autres
peut-être de voix mais qui procède d'une
façon défectueuse en tout cas d'une
façon peut-être illégale ou d'une façon
qui n'est pas correcte au règlement elle
ne pourra pas non plus alors pourquoi
exclure les personnes physiques je
trouve c'est une limitation extrêmement
forte et là encore je sais que à chaque
fois qu'on fait référence à des textes
internationaux il y a toujours quelques
que grincement dedans mais en même temps
c'est la réalité dans laquelle nous
vivons et nous sommes tous profondément
européens et donc si je regarde la
recommandation du Conseil de l'Europe et
bien je vois qu'il y a aucune
distinction entre personne morale et
personne physique lorsqu'on définit les
lanceurs d'alerte et si je regarde
l'étude excellente je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure de février 2016 du Conseil
d'État et bien je vois non plus qu'il y
a pas de distinction donc vraiment
essayer de retenir que la notion de
personne et on aura les personnes
physiques et les personnes morales qui
pourront être protégé merci Monsieur
Anziani le 547 rectifié
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
mes chers collègues il est question ici
de définir un statut général du lanceur
d'alerte qui permettrait d'assurer à
l'individu une protection spécifique
après qu'il est signalé un crime un
délit ou une violation grave et
manifeste de la loi ou du règlement il
s'agit notamment de faire en sorte qu'il
ne puisse être licencié sanctionné
professionnellement ni sa candidature ne
puisse être écarté un tel statut existe
déjà aujourd'hui dans le domaine de
l'environnement de la santé publique et
il est aujourd'hui question de l'étendre
à tous les domaines la crainte partagée
par une grande partie des membres du
groupe RDSE est devoir courtcircuiter
l'autorité judiciaire dont on connaît
les difficultés budgétaires il ne
faudrait pas que des individus adoptent
le REFX de systématiquement se tourner
vers la presse plutôt que vers les
tribunaux quand ils observent des
violations de la loi ou du règlement
nous sommes donc majoritairement
favorables à un statut deur d'alerte qui
soit subsidiaire de l'action du juge qui
la complète et qui intervienne en
dernier recours le présant amendement a
donc pour objet d'inscrire la référence
de l'article 40 du code de procédure
pénale au cœur même de la définition des
lanceur d'alerte pour rappeler que le
recours au juge doit rester la procédure
normale et le statut de Lan d'alerte
l'exception
merci Monsieur requier le 379 madame
Blandin l'argumentation est la même que
le sous-amendement à l'amendement du
Gouvernement il réintroduit des
précisions avec les termes de santé
environnement liberté finance sécurité
au côté de l'intérêt
général merci Madame Landin le 311
monsieuri monsieur le Président c'est un
un mixte à la fois nous reprenons
des termes de l'amendement du du
gouvernement sur l'engagement
international oui évidemment on a le
droit de dénoncer un manquement un un
engagement international ratifié par la
France ou approuvé par la France et puis
en même temps aussi les termes de ce que
vient de dire Madame Blondin je ne
comprends pas pourquoi dans le texte de
la commission des lois on a abandonné ce
qui figurait dans le texte l'Assemblée
nationale c'est-à-dire des faits
présentant des risques ou des préjudices
graves pour l'environnement la santé ou
la sécurité publique monsieur le
rapporteur va nous dire qu'en réalité
c'est reporté dans d'autres endroits du
texte oui mais l'endroit où on définit
c'est bien cet article et dans la
définition et je crois qu'il est tout à
fait utile de préciser ces éléments
merci Monsieur Anziani le 528 rectifié
monsieur
Colomba bien non déplaise à ma collègue
Blandin un lanceur
d'alerte c'est pas un Riverin un Riverin
il semble qu'il y a une confusion entre
droit d'expression
et puis la situation de quelqu'un qui de
par sa position a des informations que
les autres n'ont pas et surtout est en
position de faiblesse par rapport à son
employeur rien n'empêche un Riverin de
de dire ce que vous faites là c'est
dangereux c'est contraire à ceci c'est
contraire à cela qu'est-ce qui au plus
qu'est-ce qui risque ben d'être attaqué
pour diffamation et quand on sait quand
on sait à quel conditions on peut être
condamné pour diffamation on a quand
même pas trop de souciis là-dessus donc
si en plus il y a quand même anguille
suroch sousroche par contre le problème
est totalement différent pour des gens
qui dépendent d'un employeur qui dénonce
finalement ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
de leur de leur entreprise parce que
toute la question qu'on se pose c'est
quel est la quel est l'équilibre à
maintenir entre effectivement la
protection de ceux qui prennent des
risques et ceux qui n'en prennent pas
ceux qui dénoncent effectivement ce qui
ressemble à des infraction et puis les
autres c'est quand même ça aussi donc il
me semble et en plus j'ai eu la joie de
constater que c'était apparemment ce que
la Cour de cassation partageait à peu
près cette façon de voir les choses
enfin ça n'avait pas de rapport au début
donc centrer cela dans le cas de la
relation de travail ça me para
paraîtrait une bonne manière d'éviter un
certain nombre de dérives et de protéger
ceux qui méritent le plus d'être
protégés parce qu'ils sont effectivement
en
danger merci Monsieur Colomba alors
monsieur le rapporteur on commence par
le 309 rectifié monsieur le Président
j'ai amendements j'ai 16
minutes oui allez-y monsieur le
rapporteur vous les avez merci beaucoup
bien c'est quand même la définition est
difficile
puisque madame Goulet nous en propose
une madame Blandin nous en propose une
monsieur anzian nous en propose une
monsieur le ministre nous en propose
une monsieur Colomba nous en propose un
peu moins mais nous en propose une c'est
un peu plus loin et la Commission
propose une force de constater que c'est
pas très facile de trouver une
définition à à ce lanceur d'alerte alors
moi j'ai beaucoup entendu et je vais
faire première observation j'ai beaucoup
entendu que toutes les observations
c'étaient c'était le cas d'Antoine
Deltour et monsieur le ministre vous
m'avez dit mais prouvez-moi
démontrez-moi que votre définition
permet Antoine Deltour d'être protégé si
je vous le démontre on en reste à la
définition de la commission
alors le
cadre voilà le cas le cas d'Antoine
Deltour est bien visé par la définition
du lanceur d'alerte retenu par la
commission la commission un lanceur
d'alerte est une personne physique qui
signale dans l'intérêt général de
manière désintéressé de bonne foi un
crime un délit ou une violation grave et
manifeste de la loi ou du règlement qui
n pas forcément un délit ou un crime
dont il a eu personnellement
connaissance or certaines pratiques
abusives visant à se soustraire à
l'impôt sont des violations graves et
manifestes de la loi même si ce ne sont
pas des délits et bien et dans le cas de
de d'Antoine Deltour c'était un peu ce
qu'il y avait derrière je pense à
l'article 64 du livre des procédure
fiscale qui définit l'abut de droit
l'abut de droit qui permet de
caractériser les ement signalé par
Monsieur Deltour je vous dis l'abus de
droit en fiscal c'est le fait de
rechercher c'est le texte Rechercher le
bénéfice d'une application littérale des
textes ou de décision à l'encontre des
objectifs poursuivis par leurs auteurs
fait qui n'ont pu être inspiré par aucun
autre motif que celui d'éluder ou
d'atténuer les charges fiscales de
l'intéressé actuellement l'abus de droit
fiscal n'est pas pénalement sanctionné
mais pour autant c'est néanmoins
par le livre des procédures fiscales
donc avec not avec notre définition
Antoine Deltour est protégé en France il
ne l' pas au Luxembourg pour toutes les
raisons que nous avons donné tout à
l'heure donc je vous rappelle d'ailleurs
qu'antoineour au Luxembourg est
poursuivi pour divulgation du secret des
affaires qui n'est d'ailleurs pas un
délit en France mais surtout qu'il est
poursuivi pour sêre introduit
frauduleusement dans un système
informatique tout lanceur d'alerte n'a
peut-être pas systématiquement à
s'introduire frauduleusement dans un
système informatique je livre toutes ces
explications à votre euh sagacité j'en
viens maintenant aux amendements alors
bon j'ai plusieurs définition je vais en
revenir à celle qui a ma faiblesse
c'est-à-dire celle de la commission des
lois alors euh l'amendement de de de de
Madame Goulet alors euh vous élargissez
considérablement la notion de lanceur
d'alerte vous en êtes d'ailleurs
d'accord vous ne vous en cachez pas et
vous euh prévoyez ce qui fait que je
vous donnerai un avis défavorable ou
peut-être vous le retirerez cet
amendement prévoit qu'une personne
morale peut être un lanceur d'alerte
lanceur d'alerte c'est pas un brevet de
gloire ni un titre de gloire un lanceur
d'alerte pour nous c'est c'est un moyen
de défense il va se défendre contre une
violation du secret professionnel qu'il
a commis avec l'accord de la loi et il
va se défendre contre une discrimination
dont il fait l'objet dans son travail
lanceur d'alerte c'est avant tout un
moyen de défendre et ça peut pas être
une personne morale une personne morale
une société connaî pas pas
personnellement une situation ça passe
bien sûr par nécessairement une personne
physique et si nous voulons un
responsable faut pas que ce soit une
personne morale donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons exclu la
personne morale qui élargirait
considérablement peut-être le champ
desanceur d'alerte mais qui en plus
dilurait totalement totalement la
responsabilité de celle-ci donc je vous
demande de bien vouloir le retirer si
vous ne le retirez pas j'ai mets à la
demande de la Commission un avite
défavorable pour le alors la la
définition du gouvernement qui est
certes un peu plus restrictive que celle
de de de de Monsieur Anziani qui
peut-être d'ailleurs permettra de de de
de réfléchir mais pour autant qu'est-ce
que c'est que tout risque ou préjudice
grave pour l'intérêt général je pense
que là c'est pas assez précis et je ne
crois pas qu'un renvoi à la notion
d'intérêt général non pas comme une
condition comme le prévoit le texte de
la commission mais comme un motif de
l'alerte soit conforme à la
jurisprudence constittu de cette
définition n'est tout de même une
irresponsabilité pénale ou l'application
de délit prévu par le droit commun et je
considère je pense ne pas avoir été
écouté tout à l'heure que vous mettez un
peu le défenseur d'alerte en difficulté
lui-même lorsque le juge à la fin
considérera votre définition tellement
grande qu'il considérera que c'est plus
un lanceur d'alerte donc c'est
évidemment aussi un avis
défavorable évidemment les amendements
de Madame Blandin c'est exactement pour
la même raison puisque vous vous ajoutez
après toute oui vous précisez mais vous
ajoutez une liste l'environnement la
santé les libertés lesquelles les
finances les oui les finances la
sécurité publique donc encore une fois
la loi pénale est d'inprétation strict
et je crains que sur ce point on ait
quelques difficulté et que le Conseil
constitutionnel nous renvoie revoir
notre copie donc c'est également un un
avis défavorable enfin enfin la
l'article pardon l'amendement 310
personne morale je me suis expliqué à
l'occasion du de l'amendement de Madame
Goulet je ne pense pas personnellement
qu'une personne morale soit capable de
connaître personnellement d'un fait mais
c'est un débat avis défavorable après
l'amendement de monsieur mzard qui vise
à prévoir qu'un lanceur d'alerte doit
être une personne n'ayant pu utiliser
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
alors là je pense qu'il y a une
confusion là il y a une confusion euh
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
ne concerne que les agents publics et
les agents publics oui alors
contrairement je vois qu'on va être
d'accord sur ce point monsieur le
ministre contrairement à l'alerte
l'article 40 pose donc une obligation de
dénoncer un délit ou un crime dont un
fonctionnaire un agent public pardon a
eu connaissance de l'exercice de ses
fonctions le lanceur d'alerte n'est pas
un fonctionnaire qui signale au
procureur de la République des faits
dont il a l'obligation de de les
dénoncer alors dans cette hypothèse il
doit évidemment suivre les procédure qui
s'impose à lui et notamment l'article 40
c'est pas non plus une victime c'est pas
un témoin c'est pas un journaliste c'est
pas forcément le le le voisin qui est
victime d'une situation il a d'autres
possibilités pour faire ça il il se
plaint au procureur de la République
dans les 3 mois s'il a pas de réponse il
saisit le le juge d'instruction ou il va
voir un journaliste ou il exprime son
opinion comme disait notre collègue tout
à l'heure donc c'est pas la même chose
voyez que le débat on a chacun nos
convictions nos certit c'est pas du tout
évident c'est pas du tout évident on
regarde des conséquences que pourront
avoir les signalements faits par des
lanceurs d'alerte quelquefois de bonne
foi quelque foois d'ailleurs de bonne
foi peut-être même toujours de bonne foi
mais la bonne foi ça veut pas dire qu'il
y aura pas des dégâts après donc c'est
également là un avis défavorable madame
Blondin après je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure la définition me paraît large
puis trop large je m'en suis expliqué
tout à l'heure c'est évidemment le même
avis des FA favorable sur l'amendement
de monsur anzian c'est l'élargissement
de la notion de lanceur d'alerte je
parle de l'amendement 311 c'est
évidemment de même nature
l'argumentation est exactement de même
nature enfin enfin un amendement
intéressant qui va peut-être susciter un
débat et j'en auraai bientôt fini c'est
l'amendement de Monsieur Colomba ou en
tout cas qui a été présenté par votre
groupe qui vise à encadrer la définition
du lanceur d'alerte limitant les
informations pouvant être signalées à
celles issues d'une relation de travail
vous avez fait allusion à un arrêt
extrêmement récent
de la Cour de cassation qui d'ailleurs
n'est pas une révolution dans le droit
puisqueen matière de droit social
euh on ne peut pas justifier un
licenciement pour faute grave parce
qu'un employé a dénoncé un délit au sein
de son entreprise ça ne s'est encore pas
trop vu en matière de de droit du
travail donc là ça me semble être une
précision utile en tout cas c'est ce que
j'ai dit à la commission qui a bien
voulu me suivre et donner un avis de de
sagesse la protection des lanceurs
d'alertees n'existe que par rapport au
risque de représaill qui pèse sur les
personnes or si la personne dénonce des
faits extérieurs à son employeur
risque pas de représail pas plus qu'elle
ne risque sur des représailles sur son
contrat de travail c'est pas son
employeur elle a pas non plus violé un
secret professionnel donc elle a pas
être protégée de violer un secret
professionnel qu'elle n'a pas violé
c'est une victime dépose si dépose pas
plainte que c'est une faute civile et
bien va dans le tribunal civil et
demande une indemnisation sur fondement
de l'article 1382 du code civil si c'est
un témoin il est protégé un témoin c'est
protégé lorsque ça témoigne si c'est un
journaliste il a le secret des sources
donc là
aussi sur ce point pardon à l'inverse
j'ai metis un avis de sagesse voire
favorable merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le
ministre
bien monsieur le Président je crois que
nous allons pas reprendre tous les
arguments mais pardon monsieur le
rapporteur vous ne m'avais pas
convaincu je je veux non mais je veux
juste mais mais franchement nous sommes
tous de bonne fois donc je pense que si
on regarde les choses en face on devrait
pouvoir au moins sur les diagnostic et
tomber d'accord
euh je je reparle encore de de looklix
looklix est-ce que c'est une entreprise
qui comme on pourrait le dire en France
commet un abus de
droit la réponse est non puisque luxlix
c'est le gouvernement qui accorde
entreprise par entreprise une on appelle
ça justement rescr là-bas en français si
on dirait rescrit qui autorise cette
entreprise pour l'avenir à ne payer
quasiment pas d'impôt ce qui a choqué
monsieur Deltour on peut le comprendre
c'est qu'il a eu connaissance de toute
une série de situation de cette nature
et qu'il a porté à l'extérieur
connaissance de situation anormale
tellement anormale que la loi a changé
au Luxembourg et que maintenant je le
répète pour tous ceux qui ne m'auraient
pas écouté cette disposition existe dans
l'ensemble des pays de des 28 pays 28
encore de l'Union européenne donc je ne
transpose pas ensuite en France mais
c'est juste ce que je voudrais vous dire
imaginons imaginons qui est aujourd'hui
en
France un gouvernement un ministre
peut-être un ministre des Finances qui
se met à accorder à toute une série
d'entreprises des reséscrits comme ça
lui permettant de ne payer aucun impôt
et imaginons qu'il y ait un salarié dans
ses entreprises ou bien dans une
entreprise qui s'occupe de gérer les
situations et qui disent ceci est
anormal et bien dans ce cas-là en France
votre définition ne le couvrirait pas
voilà juste après on va pas se on va pas
se convaincre sur ce point je reprends
sur les AM amendement bon monsieur le
Président comme le gouvernement fait une
proposition c'est une proposition qui se
substitue en quelque sorte ou qui est en
concurrence avec les autres propositions
et donc çaamais difficile de donner un
avis favorable aux autres amendements
que que le mien puisque sinon le mien
tomberait si les autres étaient adoptés
mais je suis sensible à ce aux arguments
de Monsieur Anziani sur la question de
la personne morale de même que je suis
sensible et aux arguments de Monsieur
Colomba sur la question du relation du
travail parce
qu'effectivement pourquoi voulons-nous
protéger le lanceur d'alerte parce que
s'il porte à la connaissance il se
mettent en danger est-ce qu'une
association dont c'est la vocation que
de défendre l'environnement ou de lutter
contre la corruption qui donne à
connaître telle ou telle situation se
met en danger non elle fait simplement
son travail sauf à être dans une
dénonciation calomnieuse ou quelque
chose de cette nature donc la réalité
des choses cétait c'est évidemment
quelqu'un qui est dans une relation de
travail au sein de l'entreprise donc je
suis sensible à cet argument et si par
la suite des discussion ceci pouvit être
prise en compte ça ne me gênerait pas
mais monsieur le Président je me résume
le l'amendement 309 417 310 547 379 31
528 étant en discussion commune et en
concurrence avec celui du gouvernement
je donne un avis qui ne peut pas être
favorable so ant que l'amendement du
Gouvernement soit adopté sous et le
sous-amendement monsieur le ministre
651 sur le sous-amendement alors madame
Blandin n'est pas du tout en
contradiction avec l'amendement du
Gouvernement elle cherche en quelque
sorte à l'illustrer non pas à le
préciser mais à l'illustrer c'est
d'ailleurs beaucoup c'est exactement
comme ça que à l'Assemblée nationale les
députés ont raisonné mais ils avaient
dit que la liste à laquelle vous
faitesion est c'était les seuls cas
d'atteintes grave dans ma proposition je
ne délimite pas définitivement les
atteintes graves mais vouslez illustrer
vous les illustrer faut faire attention
quand on illustre à ne pas restreindre
donc je pense qu'il vaut mieux avoir ma
proposition qui est un peu plus large
que celle qui risquerait de pousser à
une restriction de la définition du
lanceur d'alerte merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président
B merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre nous pouvons être en
désaccord mais il ne faut surtout pas
que nous restions sur un mal entendu
certains font de la politique fiction
nous ne faisons pas de la loi
fiction pour que nous ayons
à nous
prononcer de telle manière que jamais un
Antoine Deltour ne soit condamné en
France encore
faudrait-il que le gouvernement français
puisse
prendre des rescrits qui conduiraient à
exonérer des entreprises de charge
fiscale que l'ensemble des entreprises
de France devrait assumer le rescrit
c'est une pratique d'ailleurs très utile
qu'on pourrait songer à étendre mais
vous ne le proposez pas aujourd'hui et
qui consiste à garantir au contribuable
l'entreprise en
l'occurrence que la loi fiscale doit
être interprétée d'une certaine façon
mais certainement pas en contradiction
avec sa lettre bon et bien dans la
mesure où la législation française dans
le domaine fiscal n'étant rien
comparable à la législation
luxembourgeoise pourquoi voulez-vous que
nous fassions courir le risque par notre
définition à unantoine
Deltour intervenant en France comme
lanceur d'alerte d'être condamné si nous
adoptons le texte de la commission des
lois et même si nous ne l'adoption pas
d'une certaine façon de toute façon pour
qu'il y ait une condamnation d'un
monsieur Deltour il faut qu'il y ait la
loi luxembourgeoise et vous ne nous
proposez pas de transposer la loi
luxembourgeoise car si vous nous l'aviez
proposé alors on aurait pu légitimement
se poser la question de définir le
lanceur d'alerte comme vous souhaitez
qu'on le définisse en réalité nous avons
de mon point de vue un système clair
simple qui ne souffrira pas de
divergenence possi
d'interprétation violation non plutôt
délit crime violation de la loi et des
règlements formule très large dans
violation de la loi et des règlements
comme nous l'a dit très justement
monsieur monsieur le rapporteur à
l'instant il y a bien l'abus de droit
fiscal c'est pour moi une interprétation
qui s'impose et si nous sommes bien
d'accord là-dessus d'abord que le
contexte de la législation fiscale
française est totalement différent du
luxembourgeoise et que nous sommes aussi
d'accord pour dire que
l'article 64 du livre des Procé fiscale
qui définit l'abus de droit fiscal
s'appliquerait et permettrait d'exonérer
de sa responsabilité pénale un lanceur
d'allerre qui révélerait un abus de
droit fiscal à ce moment-là monsieur le
ministre vraiment je vous le dis c'est
c'est notre débat est juridique et
technique il n'est pas politique et dans
ce débat juridique et technique je crois
que notre discussion éclaire
suffisamment les choses pour nous
rassurer pleinement sur le fait que la
définition des lanceurs d'alertes que la
commission des lois vous propose de
donner satisfait pleinement votre
souhait qu'il n'y ait jamais de
condamnation d'un Antoine Deltour en
France Merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le
Rapporteur difficile d'apporter des
précisions après l'intervention du
président mais je voudrais uniquement
vous répondre à l'exemple que vous avez
pris un
ministre comme ça dans l'ombre distribue
des faveurs fiscales à je ne sais
quelles entreprises et un anoine Deltour
vient dénoncer cette situation il a
parfaitement raison le ministre est hors
la loi il crée il est en violation grave
et manifeste de la loi mieux mieux il
est le ministre est en train de
commettre un délit c'est le délit de
concussion on ne peut pas
volontairement renoncer à la perception
de la peau donc là dans votre exemple
Antoine Deltour non seulement il a la
première page des journaux mais il est
sanctifié rapporteur
monsieur
aniani une une observation simplement
pour simplifier le le débat et dire que
je retire l'amendement 309 au profit de
l'amendement du Gouvernement qui est
sans doute rédigé avec plus de précision
je maintiens néanmoins l' 310 qu'elle
mérite de traiter de toutes les
personnes et pas uniquement des
personnes physiques mais j'ai envie
aussi de faire une observation par
rapport au débat que je viens d'entendre
c'est vrai mais il y a un autre cas
l'autre cas c'est si on trouve par
exemple des produits
dangereux comme on a pu trouver la
miante si on trouve de la miante et que
quelqu'un signale la miante en quoi
votre premier paragraphe va-t-il
empêcher des poursuites contre la
personne et je vous rappelle qu'il y a
eu des personnes qui ont été poursuivies
parce qu'elles ont révélé l'existence de
l' miante au moment où elle révèle
l'existence de l' miante vous avez pas
un loi ou une règlement qui a interdit
la miante alors comment votre texte ne
fonctionnera pas et donc il y a des
lanceurs d'alertes tout à fait utiles
pour la santé qui ne pourront pas être
protégés monsieur Colomba i je suis bien
tout à l'heure notre collègue Anzani
nous a dit qu'il s'agissait d'aller plus
loin moi ma crainte c'est qu'on aille à
la place parce que le problème c'est
cert d'assurer la sécurité de ceux qui
notamment dans leur cadre du le cadre de
travail dénon des irrégularités et donc
se se mettre en danger mais c'est aussi
qu'on réduise progressivement ces zones
floues entre le licite et l'illicite et
vous savez bien tous que l'un des
terraau de la délinquence financière
c'est ça c'est permis pas permis c'est
entre les deux c'est permis tant que ça
rapporte enfin je reviendrai pas sur
l'affaire qui réelle qui n'a rien à
voirve avec avec ce soir enfin c'est un
peu ça hein on sait pas où on en est et
on laisse perdurer et c'est ça c'est ce
flou c'est pour ça que je je je plaide
pour le maximum de pénalisation de ces
de de ces délits parce qu'au moins ils
auront de la consistance et on évitera
je on dit que le le le le système
financier est criminogène c'est-à-dire
que il crée des tentations il crée des
tentations de
transgresser donc encore une fois pour
aller dans aller dans le sens du vent
c'est ça c'est dire on va régler le
problème parce qu'on va sécuriser les
lanceurs d'alerte on attend qu'on
dénonce qu'il y a un scandale on protège
celui qui fait leand et après on agit
non moi l'idéal pour moi ça serait que
on prévienne qu'on fasse avant qu'on fe
ce travail de
clarification merci Monsieur Colomba
madame
Gou oui monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre j'ai bien compris que les
personnes morales étaient hors de la
sphère d'entendement de notre commission
donc je je j'ai bien j'ai bien compris
reste la question des des droits
fondamentaux qui à mon avis est quand
même une une définition un tout petit
peu plus large et qui comprendrait
évidemment les les éléments soulevés par
Madame Blandin notamment toutes les
questions liées à l'environnement à la
santé et puis en revanche donc je vais
je vais retirer mon mon amendement ça
allègera les les débats mais le cadre
des relations de travail monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur n'est
n'est vraiment pas n'est vraiment pas
suffisant parce que dans dans toutes les
notes et dans toutes les instances y
compris transparency internationale
qu'on a cité à plusieurs reprises il y a
aussi les problème des bénévoles le
problème des sous-traitants le problème
des stagiaires des problèmes de gens qui
peuvent simplement avoir eu connaissance
d'un certain nombre de difficultés et je
pense que réduire la définition à des
liens de travail me semble pour le coup
extrêmement réducteur donc pour en
revenir à cet amendement 417 je le
retire considérant néanmoins que droits
fondamentaux n'était pas une notion tout
à fait absurde et je et je suis
absolument pas d'accord avec
l'amendement 528 qui limiterait pour le
coup les lanceurs d'alertes aux
relations de travail merci Madame Goul
madame monsieur
abats mais en fait il y a il y a il y a
deux choses qui deux visions qui
s'affrontent d'un côté on a je pense
assez sincèrement envie effectivement de
protéger les lanceurs d'alertes mais on
nous dit qu'il faut pas le faire trop et
puis pas trop généraliser et puis pour
pour pour éviter les abus et et autres
situations difficiles et de l'autre il y
a la volonté de créer un
statut c'était c'était l'esprit dans
lequel l'Assemblée nationale
avait écrit ce ce le son texte en
première lecture et moi il me paraît
tout à fait tout à fait correct
complet je partage effectivement l'idée
qu'il ne faut pas réduire les choses au
monde du travail parce que les pressions
dans le travail ça existe mais les
pressions sur les citoyens lambda ça
existe aussi
hein qui achète de l'eau éventuellement
on a tous vu un film célèbre en la
matière et et je pense
que les craintes qui sont exprimées d'un
de de de de dérapage mais notre droit
est suffisamment armé je suis pas un
grand spécialiste pour punir ou
dissuader tous ceux qui veulent faire de
la diffamation de de la délation tous
ceux qui voudrai se faire de la pub et
moi dans ce qui nous concerne pour pour
notre groupe nous nous sommes tout à
fait d'accord avec l'écriture en
première lecture donc nous serions
favorable à l'amendement aux amendements
du Gouvernement mais nous aimerions
aussi quand même qu'on intègre de
manière plus générale les associations
et autres personnes en même temps Madame
Blandin de deux choses l'unes soit
effectivement et là monsieur le ministre
vous avez raison soit effectivement on
on on illustre de la manière la plus
complète possible et alors à ce momentlà
il faut absolument intégrer des affaires
financière soit on illustre rien du tout
on reste sur l'intérêt général qui
inclut par nature y compris les affaires
financières les problèmes de fiscalité
et cetera merci merci Monsieur abat
madame
Landin première précision la rédaction
que je proposais mentionnait bien la
finance l'intérêt général c'était après
pour faire la voiture balée dans les
amendements qui nous restent donc après
les retraits on a une première
alternative la commission c'est crime
délit violation je suis désolée la fuite
de Binzen les émalations de Perre
chloréthylè ou le mercure dans la
rivière ne sont pas couverts comme
scénario par votre texte parce que c'est
pas c'est pas un délit volontaire c'est
pas une violation du droit c'est un
tuyau qui s'est rompu voilà ça c'est la
première chose en revanche l'amendement
du Gouvernement couvre ce scénario comme
celui de Monsieur Anzani la deuxème
alternative qui a failli séduire c'était
la proposition de Monsieur Colomba de se
limiter au monde du travail je suis
désolé mais Véronique lapidess qui était
à Vincenne et qui s'était ému du nombre
de leucémies chez les tout petits de la
maternelle dans une seule classe au
point qu'on a regardé la friche
industrielle en dessous et qu'on y a
trouvé des choses pas catholiques elle
elle était pas dans une relation de
travail et elle a été poursuivie
initialement pour diffamation
elle a eu les pires ennuis ça ça ruine
les gens pierre Meton chercheur de
lincerme qui fait une publication qui
dit la consommation de selle ruine les
artères et cause une mortalité excessive
en France se fait poursuivre par une
grande société de saline il est ruiné il
n'est pas défendu par linerme on n'est
pas dans les relations de travail là on
est un chercheur qui fait du outing sur
ce qu'il a découvert et une firme qui
lui tombe dessus donc donc il est
nécessaire de ne pas enfermer la
définition du lanceur d'alerte aux
relations de travail sinon nous
reviendrions en arrière par rapport au
droits existants merci Madame Blandin
monsieur le
rapporteur oui je voudrais répondre
directement à à Madame Blandin pour la
rassurer de manière ferme avec beaucoup
de conviction c'est que votre loi
2013 c'est grâce au Sénat si elle ne
passe pas à la trappe puisque le texte
revenant de l'Assemblée avait supprimé
ce qui vous protège et ce qui répond à
votre inquiétude puisque la Commission
nationale de déontologie est des alertes
en matière de santé et d'environnement
elle existe elle continue à exister elle
elle n'existe pas parce qu'il manque
deux membres qui ont pas été nommé
paraît-il mais bon mais elle existe donc
votre loi répond encore à votre
inquiétude et celle-là et dans celle-là
nous avons un statut général mais nous
avons précisément veillé à ce qu'il ne
puisse pas atteindre ce que vous avez ce
que je viens de citer dans votre donc
vous êtes parfaitement
parfaitement rassuré sur ce point vous
n'avez pas rajouté ce qui existe déjà et
qui a étit sauvé parce que la commission
des lois a supprimé la suppression de
l'Assemblée merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur
Vincent oui merci monsieur le Président
je crois que tout le monde comprend bien
dans la logique de la commission la
nécessité de ne pas aller vers une
société de la délation voire à créer des
situations juridiques inextricables nous
sommes tous d'accord là-dessus je
voulais tout de même souligner dans la
suite de à la suite des propos de notre
collègue Anziani que en vous calant de
manière très rigoureuse finalement sur
les principes actuels du droit vous vous
privez et vous nous privez tout de même
du traitement des situations qui sont de
plus en plus nombreuses dans notre
société qui sont qui concernent des
problèmes ou des risques qui ne sont pas
encore inscrits ou prévu ou répertoriés
dans nos principes juridiques je voulais
juste illustrer la question du secteur
financier la France a perdu des dizaines
de milliards d'euros dans plusieurs
affaires ces dernières années il est
évident qu'à l'intérieur de ces
entreprises certains salariés auraient
pu Savit que des tout à fait en capacité
de dire que des risques étaient pris
manifestement en décalage avec les
possibilités des banques concernées et
par la suite de l'ensemble de l'économie
cette ce type de d'alerte ne peut pas
être prise en compte en se calant sur
les principes qui sont les vôtres et au
contraire pourrait je le crois avec
efficacité tirer profit d'une d'une
définition qui fait référence à un
préjudice grave à l'intérêt général
parce que préjudice grave à l'intérêt
général on peut aussi espérer que dans
la qualification juridique éventuel de
de cette situation nous n'aurions que
des situations relativement
exceptionnelles par
définition merci Monsieur Vincent bien
je vais donc mettre au
voix le 646 puisque le
39 pardon le 309 rectifié a été tiré le
417 a été retiré et donc nous allons
voter sur le sous-amendement
651 avant de voter sur le
648 c'est Madame Landin si c'est pour
retirer que je le retire oui on va
retiré merci Madame landandin donc le
646 j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe
républicain sur l'amendement
646 je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable et que bien
sûr l'avis du Gouvernement est favorable
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instant voici le résultat du scrutin 413
sur l'amendement numéro
646 nombre de votants
343 nombre de suffrages exprimés
341 pour l'adoption
139 contre 202 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 414
sur l'amendement numéro 310 nombre de
votants 345 nombre de suffrages exprimés
343 pour l'adoption 139 compte 204 le
Sénat n'a pas
adopté le 547 rectifié qui été présenté
par Monsieur
Colomba qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables je le mets au voix qui est
pour qui est
contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
379 qui a été présenté par Madame
Blandin qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables comment il est
retiré le
311 est-ce qu'on peut considérer que
c'est le même vote que le
310 on est
d'accord on est d'accord même vote donc
528 rectifié qui a reçu un avis
défavorable du gouvernement et une
sagesse de la part de la
Commission pas défavorable monsieur le
ministre sur le 528
rectifié
intérêt une nouvelle notion à décrypter
merci monsieur le ministre vous nous
facilitez la
tâche bien donc intérêt sur le 528
rectifié c'est sans malice et sagesse de
la part de la Commission je le mets au
voix qui est pour Madame
Blandin vous souhaitiez vous exprimer
excusez-moi allez-y
allez-y vous prendrai que quelques
secondes pour dire que c'est vraiment
pas intéressant et que ça serait une
grande régression voilà donc je voterai
contre d'cord madame lin merci donc donc
pas d'autre explication de vote je le
mets au voix qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté al bon s'il y a doute on se lève
qui est
pour mais les
mêmes qui est
contre ça fait 11 11 il est donc donc
pas
adopté merci Monsieur le
Ministre merci
beaucoup un amendement 644 présenté par
le gouvernement monsieur le ministre ou
monsieur le Président il s'agit
de d'intégrer dès le stade de la
définition du lanceur d'alerte et non
pas ultérieurement l'exclusion du secret
de la défense nationale du secret
médical du secret des rel entre un
avocat et son client son disposition qui
avait été intégré me semble-t-il
utilement à l'Assemblée
nationale merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur la commission
n'avait pas mentionné ce texte
exactement au même endroit on peut
comprendre les craintes du gouvernement
c'est un avis favorable avis favorable
de la part de la Commission je le mets
au voix qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient et
est adopté deux amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune à 312
monsieur Anziani
oui monsieur le
Président cet article 6 ça est un
article sur la définition mais il
comporte deux alinéas le premier alinéa
dit oui nous sommes favorables au droit
d'alettre et à reconnaître un droit
d'alettre et le deuxième alinéa tout de
suite après dit ouais mais faites
attention faites attention les lanceurs
d'aleres
ça pourrait vous coûter cher c'est cette
articulation d'un côté donner une
définition en disant on est d'accord
mais juste après dire attention vous
pouvez recevoir un coup de Massu je
crois d'abord que c'est maladroit comme
définition et après je ne vois pas très
bien en dehors du fait que ça manque un
peu d'enthousiasme quand même pour les
lanceurs d'Alert je vois pas très bien
l'intérêt pourquoi parce que les
sanction contre les lanceurs d'alertes
de mauvaise fois ou qui commettrait un
certain nombre d'erreurs elle existe
déjà il y a évidemment celles qui sont
citées par la ligne A2 l'article 26
22610 du code pénal l'article 1882 du
Code civil j'ajouterai qu'il y a
également la diffamation qui a également
évidemment la dénonciation calumieuse
qui a toutes les voies de procédure
civile pour réparer les préjudices
causés à autruie bien sûr elles existent
c'est pas la peine de de le mentionner
et là souvent on dit entre nous mais
faut-il que la loi bégille et on dit bah
non quand la loi prévoir quelque chose
c'est pas la peine de répéter ce qui est
dans la loi par ailleurs et là tout d'un
coup finalement notre commission des
lois qui est très sourcilleuse sur cette
faire de bégoillement dans la bois elle
trouve que c'est bien de répéter alors
moi je trouve que c'est une erreur une
erreur de de rédaction je pense qu'on
aurait pu néanmoins faire un article sur
la responsabilité je pense qu'on aurait
pu le faire mais pas au moment de la
définition il est quand même paradoxal
qu'au moment de la définition on
retienne la sanction et qu'on retienne
pas la protection je voudrais bien
savoir pourquoi dans la définition on
met pas la protection du lanceur
d'alerte non on préfère la protection
l'enlever et lui consacrer d'autres
articles mais la sanction tout de suite
le mettre avec la définition je pense
que c'est particulièrement maladroit
merci monsieurri Anani le 544 rectifié
monsieur
requier mes chers collègues cet
amendement a pour objet de prévenir une
utilisation dévoyer du statut général de
lanceur d'alerte il s'agit de prévoir la
large diffusion d'une éventuelle
décision de condamnation prise à
l'encomte d'un individu qui aurait
utilisé le statut de lanceur d'alerte
pour faire des dénonciations comneuse
par voie de presse cet amendement vise
donc à inscrire dans le corps de la
définition du lanceur d'alerte une mise
en garde pour ceux qui souhaiterit
utiliser ces statuts à des fins détourné
à la suite de la référence au articles
226 10 du code pénal et
1382 du code civil ajouté par le
rapporteur merci Monsieur requier
monsieur le rapporteur oui monsieur le
Président bon on cherche un équilibre on
a voulu l'écrire dans la loi le lanceur
d'alerte est protégé en revanche on
redit on dit que ça peut pas être à
n'importe quel prix et sans une
responsabilité bon la loi le dit elle
aurait peut-être pu ne pas le dire mais
là au moins ça pose le problème et puis
ça pose le problème la loi elle est
faite pour être lu y compris par les
lanceurs d'alertes ce qui fait qu'au
moins là elle sera claire et que
personne ne sera censé l'ignorer donc
voilà la raison pour laquelle la
commission des lois a donné un dévit
défavorable à cette suppression sur
l'autre amendement la précision qu'il
propose concernant les
publicités paraît totalement inutile
puisque le code pénal prévoit déjà des
peines de complémentaires de publicité
de de l'information de même d'ailleurs
la loi de 1881 sur la liberté de la
presse permet l'application de plusieurs
dispositions en en matière de
diffamation donc là il est pas utile
d'inscrire ces dispositions puisque
elles existent déjà donc là je vous
suggère de le le le retrait merci
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre alors monsieur le Président sur
le 312 favorable et le 544 défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre pour
l'explication de
vote monsieur
abat sur le
oui nous nous serons défavorables sur
ces deux articles je crois que ça
illustre bien ce qu'on ce qu'on
expliquit il y a d'un côté effectivement
une volonté de protéger un peu mais très
timoré on a très peur des dérapages et
en même temps vous avouez vous-même par
votre amendement
que et bien le dispositif législatif il
existe qui évite ces dérapages on nous
dit souvent que la loi est
bavarde fait état euh je vois pas du
tout l'utilité sauf que répète ça ça ça
illustre parfaitement la problématique
dans laquelle on se trouve il s'agit de
définir un statut pour les lanceurs
d'alertes et non pas d'emblé
effectivement de prévoir des sanctions
au cas où les lanceurs d'alertes
feraient des des des choses illégales
c'est pas l'esprit là dans lequel nous
abordons ce texte et donc ces deux
amendements nous paraissent enfin nous
ne voterons pas ces ces deux amendements
merci Monsieur abat madame Goulet oui
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues moi je
voterai pas non plus ces deux
amendements pour une raison assez simple
on a on a vu depuis plusieurs années que
finalement la loi avait du mal à mettre
en place ce statut des des lanceurs
d'alertes c'est pour ça qu'il est
tellement éclaté donc aujourd'hui nous
avons nous avons ce statut que nous
sommes en train de de voter mais en même
temps ce statut doit pas être de la
délation et puis il est absolument
indispensable de rappeler les
responsabilités des lanceurs d'alertes
pour une raison très simple c'est que le
temps judiciaire entre le lanceur
d'alerte et la réparation en cas
d'alerte de fausse alerte j'allais dire
ce temps judiciaire là est extrêmement
long et le rapporteur et le président de
la commission des lois l'ont l'ont très
bien rappelé tout à l'heure une
entreprise qui aurait été victime d'un
lanceur d'alerte de façon abusive va
mettre des années à à à récupérer ou ou
à retrouver une une position si si
jamais ce lanceur d'alerte n'a pas
purement et simplement réduit à à la
faillite ou ou pire donc en raison de ce
décalage du du temps judiciaire
notamment de la réparation d'une alerte
qui serait qui serait une une fausse
alerte je pense qu'il est absolument
indispensable de rappeler en même temps
que la définition les limites de
l'exercice donc moi je voterai pas ces
deux amendements et je maintiendrai le
le texte tel qu'il est merci Madame
Goulet monsieur Colomba moi non plus je
ne le voterai pas il semble qu'une des
spécialités de notre pays c'était ce
serait de de passer d'une extrémité à
l'autre quand on se rappelle
effectivement le le scandale de de de la
miante c'est c'est ça a été absolument
dramatique il a fallu des années et des
années et des années pour que ça
aboutisse et maintenant c'est l'inverse
tout le monde va pouvoir lancer des
alertes mettre en danger qui voudra
après ça fonder ou pas bah on verra
après hein de toute façon il lance des
alertes alors ma foi bon donc je pense
quand même rappeler aux gens qu'ils
engagent aussi un peu leur
responsabilités c'est peut-être pas
quand même complètement complètement
stupide franchement moi je
oui bah j'espère que alors pourquoi
s'acharner sur peut-être ce qui peut
apparaître redondant mais qui mais qui
est qui est quand même bienvenu vous ne
réalisez pas bien non plus parce que il
y a eu des dangers et et des des
iniquités majeures de sens inverse où on
s'engage monsieur Colomba donc je vais
mettre le 312 au vote qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et un avis
favorable du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le 544 rectifié
monsieur requier il est retiré merci
Monsieur requier un 134 ensuite
rectifieré TER madame
doromeddi merci monsieur le Président il
importe de préciser les conditions dans
lesquelles la diffusion des fausses
informations par un lanceur d'alerte
peut être empêché ou corrigé dans les
médias en effet des réputations peuvent
être ruinées pour une longue P période
par des fausses accusations certes le
recours aux dispositions du droit commun
offre des garanties aux personnes lésées
mais il a paru nécessaire d'apporter des
précisions dans un souci de plus grande
rapidité des décisions dans les cas les
plus urgents merci madame deormédi
monsieur le rapporteur si si rassuré
c'est convaincre je vais essayer de vous
rassurer en vous disant que
euh cet amendement est satisfait par les
disposition du droit en vigueur et pour
vous en dire plus je vais vous rappeler
celles qui permettent au juges des
référés euh
l'article 91 relatif au au référé
présomption d'innocence lorsqu'une
personne est avant toute condamnation
présentée publiquement comme étant
coupable de fait faisant l'objet d'une
enquête ou d'une instruction judiciaire
le juge peut même en référer sans
préjudice de la réparation du dommage
subi prescrire toute mesures tes que
l'insertion d'une rectification ou la
diffusion d'un communiqué au fin de
faire cesser l'atteinte à la
présempption d'innocent donc on a déjà
se référé là mais il y a aussi un le
référé droit de réponse et puis il y a
aussi le référé en matière d'atte à la
vie privée donc vous avez trois
procédures qui me paraissent couvrir
votre inquiétude donc je demande le
retrait merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre même avis madame
dorméi madame Goulet non juste monsieur
le ministre monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre juste une seconde
monsieur le rapporteur je comprends très
bien que cette disposition ne soit pas
conforme à l'idée que vous vous faites
de votre texte sur les lanceurs
d'alertes mais permettez-moi de vous
dire pour avoir pour avoir survécu
à ce genre d'épreuve que il y a une très
grande différence entre la loi et son
application en la matière et notamment
en matière de de diffamation ou de
respect de la vie privée donc je pense
que cette disposition probablement dans
un autre texte madame debelli devra être
reprise peut-être si un jour nous avons
une deuxième lecture convenable de la
justice du 21e siècle dans cette maison
il sera probablement temps de revoir les
dispositions relatives à la diffamation
et la protection de la vie privée parce
que je peux vous dire que c'est des
choses dont son se mais pas très
facilement et que monsieur le rapporteur
le sait le sait très bien il y a une
très très grande différence entre le
droit et son application à la matière et
je peux vous dire que j'en ai subi les
conséquences donc je comprends que cette
disposition ne s'intègre pas au lanceur
d'alerte mais c'est quand même un sujet
sur lequel on pourra éventuellement
s'appesantir un peu madame Goulet
monsieur
Vassel merci monsieur le Président le
lancecheur d'alerte est d'une création
relativement récente donc nous n'avons
pas encore beaucoup de de retour quant à
la manière dont les juges mettent en
application le dispositif que nous
sommes en train de compléter de
renforcer ceci étant le rapporteur a une
certaine bonne expérience de
l'application du droit ce qui lui permet
d'avoir une véritable crédibilité
lorsqu'il exprime un avis et que nous
avons plutôt tendance à le suivre dans
les avis qu'il exprime ceci étant je
pense que Madame Goulet n'a pas
complètement tort en considérant que les
magistrats sont quelquefois un peu
frileux quant à l'application stricte du
droit et il serait bon au vu de
l'expérience que sera la notre après la
mise en œuvre du droit et son
application de revenir peut-être en tant
que de besoin pour le préciser car
l'objectif de cet amendement déposé par
madame deomedi était simplement d'aller
plus loin dans la précision donc du
droit de telle manière à s'assurer qu'il
sera effectivement appliqué elle le dit
très bien d'ailleurs dans l'exposé
d'amendement que le droit commun est
celui qui s'asplique mais qui lui est
apparu pertinent d'aller un peu plus
loin et d'être un peu plus précis pour
que le juge soit enclin à l'appliquer
strictement donc on va sans doute madame
deedi prendra la décision le retirer
mais il était bon que nous ayons un
échange sur ce sur cet amendement merci
Monsieur Vassel Madame D romédi il est
retiré merci madame dormédi je vais
mettre au voie l'article
6a qui est
pour qui est
contre il est adopté
oui à l'article 6b un amendement 313
monsieur
Anziani
alors cet amendement simplement reprend
toujours la même le même esprit
c'est-à-dire que je considère nous
considérons que la ligé 2 de l'article
6b qui précise que les procédure
intervient dans le respect des
procédures enfin il faut qu'il
responsabilité pénale pour qu'elle
puisse être retenue respect des
procédures signalement défin par la loi
ça nous paraît tout à fait
superfitatoire en plus c'est une
répétition d'une disposition qu'on va
trouver par ailleurs encore une fois
c'est la même inspiration toujours
réduire essayer de revenir en arrière
réduire rétrécir faire en sorte que le
lanceur d'alerte soit le moins nombreux
possible et ne fasse pas peur voilà et
moi j'ai toujours envie de dire n'ayons
pas peur du lanceur d'alerte un jour ou
l'autre il pourra très bien aussi nous
être très utile merci Monsieur Anzani
monsieur le
rapporteur C am est évidemment contraire
à la position de la Commission dans tout
l'équilibre relatif au au lanceur
d'alerte puisque il vise à permettre les
responsabilité pénale des lanceurs
d'alertes peu importe qu'ils aient suivi
la
procédure par laquelle on mène de la
déclaration au référents ou au chefs
d'entreprise en passant par le chef
hiérarchique pour finir au bout du bout
si il y a pas eu d'effet à l'alerte à la
presse or c'est précisément comme cela
qu'on protège qu'on se protège des faux
lanceurs d'alertes et qu'on protège le
lanceur d'alerte lui-même d'une
éventuelle mauvais soix donc la
commission sur ce point si sur les
définitions et beaucoup de débats et qui
permettent peut-être d'imaginer queil y
a encore mieux à trouver sur la
définition là à l'inverse sur cette
procédure la Commission tient beaucoup
donc c'est un avis défavorable merci
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre sage
sagesse je vais mettre au voix ce cet
amendement j'ai été saisi d'une demande
de scrutin public par le groupe les
républicains sur cet amendement numéro
213 je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable et que l'avis
du Gouvernement a émis une sagesse le
scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants voici le résultat du scrutin
415 sur l'amendement numéro 313 nombre
de votants 3 3 nombre de suffrages
exprimés
343 pour l'adoption 139 contte 204 le
Sénat n'a pas
adopté un amendement 151 rectifié c'est
Monsieur
cor monsieur
corau nous considérons que la nulité de
l'obligation de confidentialité
notamment contractuelle doit être
inscrite dans la loi son omission selon
nous laisserait l'agent public ou le
salarié dans une totale incertitude
quant à la hiérarchie de ces divers
droits et obligation face à l'alerte
d'où notre proposition d'insérer après
l'alinéa 2 un alinéa ainsi rédigé toute
obligation de confidentialité faisant
obstacle au signalement ou à la
révélation d'une information définie au
première alignéa est réputé
nul monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
président euh cet amendement inverse la
logique du lanceur d'alerte un lanceur
d'alerte sa violation sa vocation pardon
à violer un secret professionnel voire
même des obligations légales néanmoins
en contrepartie lorsque cette alerte est
faite dans l'intérêt général il va
bénéficier d'une protection pénale
contre les éventuels délits ainsi commis
mais également d'une protection dans ses
relations dans sa relation de travail
dès lors il est pas nécessaire de
réputer nul toute obligation de confin
alité les protéger par les éléments que
je viens de décrire et en plus je pense
que cet amendement pourrait être
dangereux pour la protection des secrets
parce qu'il aurait pour conséquence une
absence totale de confidentialité même
en l'absence d'un lanceur d'alerte voilà
la raison pour laquelle la Commission
des loismis un avis défavorable merci
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre je ne suis pas le rapporteur je
ne le suis pas je ne suis pas le
rapporteur mais je ne le suis pas et
donc je donne un avis favorable merci
Monsieur le Ministre madame Landin pour
explication de
vote nous soutiendrons cet amendement et
je vais vous raconter une anecdote
vraie quand après le Médiator lapsaps a
muté en agence du médicament nous étions
dans les années
2012-23 on venait de voter ici la loi
lanceur d'alerte en matière de santé et
un salarié de cette nouvelle agence du
médicament m'a alerté en disant
attention ils sont en train de refaire
le règlement et dans le règlement les
commissions de vigilance sur les retours
d'information sur les effets néfastes
des médicaments ça va être complètement
verrouillé on Nura plus le droit de
parler c'était dans le règlement
heureusement le directeur de l'agence à
cette époque- là était Dominique
maranqui avec lequel j'avais travaillé
dans le cadre du Grenel un coup de
téléphone et leurs deux avocats a
arrangé les choses le règlement a été
changé mais vous voyez les mauvaises
habitudes peuvent très vite revenir pas
forcément de la part d'un président ou
d'un directeur mais d'un cadre zé qui
s'arrangerait bien tout verrouillé donc
cet amendement est très utile merci y y
a-t-il d'autres explications de
vote je le mets donc au
voix monsieur
rapporteur non vous voulez pas que je
réponde non c'est avec pas beaucoup
d'enousi que vous écouteriez ce que je
vais vous dire donc on va laisser faire
le
vote comment non non mais je voulais
réexpliquer que
réellement monsieur le rapporteur ne
vous inquiétez pas c'était pas sur vous
l'expression c'est par rapport au
collègues qui voyait un scrutin public
arriver alors exprimez-vous monsieur le
rapporteur
allez-y si ça permet d'éviter un scrutin
oui je voulais redire que la protection
qui est apportée au lanceur d'alerte ne
nécessite plus d'un cri d'inscrire que
toute obligation de confidentialité fait
obstacle au signalement ou la révélation
d'une information définie au premier
alinéa puisque de toute façon le lanceur
d'alerte va pouvoir violer un secret
professionnel va être va avoir une
immunité une immunité pénale et que
parallèlement il va peut-être être
considéré comme ayant été discriminé et
il va être protégé dans les les comment
dirais-je les préjudices qu'il pourrait
subir sur son lieu de travail donc de
toute façon ça n'apportera rien de plus
au lanceur d'alerte si ce n'est une
imperfection dans la loi qui laisserait
supposer que ça peut être utilisé par
des gens qui ne sont pas lanceurs
d'alerte merci Monsieur rapporteur je
j'été saisi donc sur cet amendement
d'une demande de secrire publque par le
groupe les républicains sur cet
amendement
151 je rappelle l'avis de la mission qui
est défavorable et l'avis du
gouvernement qui est favorable le
scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants voici le résultat du scrutin
numéro 416 sur l'amendement numéro 151
rectifié nombre de votants 343 nombre de
suffrage exprimé
326 pour l'adoption 139 contre
187 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
5 madame
trely rappel au règlement également
monsieur le Président l'intervention de
monsieur raou n'est pas un rappel au
règlement dans le règlement il est
stipuler que nous pouvons organiser
autant de scrutin public que nous le
souhaitons donc ce n'est pas un rappel
au règlement le règlement est
parfaitement
respecté
bien je pense que les choses sont
claires donc nous nons continuer et donc
un amendement 645 qui est présenté par
le gouvernement monsieur le ministre oui
monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement totalement de cohérence avec
l'amendement numéro
644 monsieur le ministre le 92 rectifié
n'est pas
défendu le
422 monsieur gatola
oui merci monsieur le président mes
chers collègues il s'agit d'une
modification rédactionnelle l'article 6b
se fixe pour objectif d'assurer
l'articulation entre l'alerte éthique et
les secrets notamment professionnels qui
sont pénalement protégés il exonère
ainsi la respons de responsabilité
pénale le lanceur d'alerte qui a émis un
signalement répondant au critères
évoqués précédemment et notamment celui
de la bonne foi aussi lors de l'examen à
l'Assemblée nationale les députés ont
souhaité que les cas du secret de la
défense nationale du secret médical et
du secret des avocats soit expressément
exclus de ce dispositif et continue donc
à être opposable au lanceur d'alerte
nous considérons toutefois que la
rédaction actuelle du du texte utilisant
l'expression je cite secret des
relations entre un avocat et son client
manque de clarté en effet cette
expression n'est utilisée dans aucun
texte de loi c'est pourquoi nous vous
proposons d'y substituer l'expression
plus générique de secret professionnel
de l'avocat je vous remercie merci
Monsieur
gatelin le 272 rectifié qu'inqu n'est
pas défendu le 487 non plus donc à vous
monsieur le rapporteur sur l'amendement
du Gouvernement c'est av c'est un avis
favorable sur le deuxè qui vient qui est
subsistant et qui vient d'être exposé
euh cet amendement t à étendre la
protection àlolue dont bénéficient les
avocats or seul le secret des relations
entre un avocat et son client est
absolument protéger non pas
l'intégralité de l'activité
professionnelle d'un avocat y compris en
dehors de ses relations avec un client
c'est donc un avis défavorable pourant
que le secret de de l'avocat et de son
client est amplement et nettement
indiqué dans la loi merci monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre donc sur
sur l'amendement 422 merci monsieur le
ministre je mets donc au voix
le 645 qui reçu un avis favorable de la
commission qui est
pour c'est l'amendement qui a été
présenté par le gouvernement qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté sur
le les autres tomb donc nous allons
voter l'article 6b qui est
pour qui est
contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté après
l'article
6b un amendement
585 qui est présenté par Monsieur
gatolin Merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le présent amendement a pour objet de
protéger les lanceurs d'alerte qui
découvrira des failles de sécurité
informatique en effet d'une telle
disposition dans notre législation mène
à des situations ubuesques où des
lanceurs d'alertes sont condamnés par la
justice alors qu'ils ont non seulement
fait la preuve de n'avoir aucune
intention de nuire mais qu'ils ont
également rendu un service notable aux
responsables des systèmes informatiques
concernés l'article
323-1 ala 1 du Code pénal sanctionne
aujourd'hui tout accès non autorisé un
système de traitement automatisé de
données cet amendement prévoit ainsi
l'immunité pénale pour l'auteur de
l'infraction lorsque celui-ci révèle
immédiatement à qui de droit la faille
de sécurité découverte et évite ainsi
qu'il soit porté atteinte au système au
système par ce biais il ne s'agit bien
sûr pas de dédoiner un pirate
informatique puisque le lanceur
d'alettre n'est pas protégé par cette
immunité s'il supprime ou modifie les
données du système comme le prévoit
l'alinéa 2 de l'article 323-1 du code
pénal si nous n'adoptons pas cet
amendement les lanceurs d'alertte qui
trouveraiit des failles de sécurité
seront dissuadés de les signaler le
résultat serait dommageable à la
sécurité nationale puisque cela
augmenterait le nombre de failles de
sécurité non corrigé car non signalé aux
responsables des systèmes informatiques
je vous remercie merci Monsieur gâelin
monsieur le rapporteur oui alors là la
commission
a donné un avis radicalement défavorable
si on peut ajouter ce mot à la à cet
avis en effet d'abord premièrement ça
rétablit une disposition qui a été
introduite par l'Assemblée nationale
dans le projet de loi numérique et
supprimé par le Sénat toute personne
selon cet amendement toute personne qui
accéderait frauduleusement et
intentionnellement dans un système de
traitement automatisé de données afin de
supprimer des données ou d'en altérer
son fonctionnement devrait être exempté
de peine dès lors que aurait contacté
après son forfait le responsable du
traitement en cause ou l'autorité
administrative ce dispositif crée ainsi
une immunité pénale pour tous les haœurs
dès lors que ces derniers préviennent
une autorité après leur acte c'est
évident qu'une telle immunité ne peut
qu'encourager le développement des
attaques informatiques puisqu'il
suffirait à priori d'un seul courriel ou
email pour échapper à toute peine donc
que c'est un avis défavorable cela
d'ailleurs offrirait aussi une une
immunité même à ceux qui attaque sans
succès un service automatisé de données
du fait d'une sécurité convenable donc
la commission des lois émis un avis très
défavorable merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre défavorable je le
mets au voix qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté à l'article 6c une demande de
parole de madame
Blandin une de j'ai dit une demande de
parole de Madame mariechristine Blandin
vous avez la parole excusez-moi monsieur
le Président il y avait des bavards
derrière moi cet article décrit la
procédure de remonée des alertes le
Sénat propose une gradation qui a le
mérite de présupposer que dans la
majeure partie des cas le fonctionnement
et la
communication interne d'une entreprise
ou d'une instance sont à même de générer
le traitement du problème mais la loi se
doit de prévoir la gestion des
exceptions dommageables pour l'intérêt
public et de protéger les faibles lors
du débat à l'Assemblée nationale on a
bien senti que le ministère était
préoccupé par la résolution dans notre
droit de récent scandal financier dont
les victimes peuvent être le budget de
la Nation l'image des institutions
bancaires voire de Bery et en fin et
ceci est profondément injuste des
individus vertueux qui ont rendu public
ces scandales c'est très bien mais la
présentation qui a été faite de cette
partie du texte inspirée par les
recommandations du rapport d'état montre
aussi une autre ambition installer une
définition et une procédure compatible
avec tous les types d'alertes je
remercie au passage la commission des
lois d'avoir rétabli un alinéa
indispensable de ma loi un peu
attivement supprimé par l'Assemblée les
amendements que je présenterai dans le
6c prennent en compte les spécificités
d'alerte d'un autre type que financier
et leurs exigences propres repensz au
médiator aux alertes internes des
agences sanitaires au risques à la fois
imminents et récurrent comme celui des
iradiers de l'hôpital
d'pinal et vous comprendrez que dans
certains cas 3 mois c'est trop parce que
le texte qui nous est proposé installe
le respect de la procédure comme
constitutif de la bonne foi il faut par
exemple prévoir tous les casre figure
comme la consultation d'association
spécialisée de type transparenci ou les
périphériques vous parlent ce que fait
l'amendement 331 elles ne sont pas palié
elles sont consultants enfin on peut
retenir les les trois premiers critères
de la qualification de la bonne foi qui
existe dans notre droit de la presse
arrêt du 6 juin 2007 la légitimité du
but poursuivi l'absence d'animosité
personnelle la prudence et la mesure
dans l'expression sans qu'il soit
nécessaire de l'enfermer dans le respect
d'une procédure en toutes
circonstances madame
Blandin monsieur Colomba pour défendre
le 589 rectifié
bien donc il
s'agit lanceur d'un lancement d'alerte
dans le cadre des relations de travail
puisqu'il y a des hiérarchies des
employeurs enfin et cetera donc encore
une fois de préciser la gradation des
opérations à à mettre en œuvre pour
arriver Infiné à au fait de rendre au
public l'alerte avec bon disons le
l'originalité par rapport à aux autres
façon de d'articuler les différentes
phases c'est un que on en a sauté dire
que c'est beaucoup plus court ensuite
donc il y a référence à la Commission
nationale de déontologie je l'ai pas
oublié pour justement tout ce qui
concerne les problèmes de santé
d'environnement et cetera et puis bien
sûr l'agence de prévention de la
corruption qui est notre objet l'objet
de cette l'objet de cette de cette
proposition de ce projet de loi donc
voilà l'essentiel donc de des objectifs
et des modalités proposé par cet
amendement merci Monsieur Colomba
monsieur le rapporteur
oui euh écoutez très rapidement c'est il
s'agit d'une réécriture de la procédure
de signalement à chaque fois que les
amendements proposeront une réécriture
de cette procédure à laquelle vous avez
bien noté que la Commission tenait
beaucoup je euh donnerai un avis
défavorable merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre euh même avis même
avis je le mets au
voix qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté voilà pour les débats des
sénateurs hier soir consacrés au
lanceurs d'alerte à leur définition à
leur protection c'est l'une des
dispositions phare de ce projet de loi
Sapin 2 qui en comporte bien d'autres
notamment l'encadrement de l'activité
des lobby auprès des pouvoirs publqus et
également tout un pan sur la
modernisation de la vie économique vous
pouvez toujours voir et revoir toutes
les séances sur notre site
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée sur
les chaînes
parlementaires